All right.
Before we go back to talking about John Bolton,
I want to talk with you today about corporations
supporting Black Lives Matter and donating
to Black Lives Matter.
And I want to hear from you about whether
you believe that I am too cynical about this
issue because I don't believe corporations
supporting or not supporting Black Lives Matter
is really indicative of any of their moral
points of view or even necessarily of the
politics of the company.
These mostly are business calculations, and
I'm actually going to go even further in the
analysis.
This is by design.
We should not even expect corporations to
really function on any basis other than how
much money is this going to make us?
Because this is how they are designed.
In particular, publicly traded corporations
have a fiduciary responsibility to their shareholders
to deliver a return and to make money.
So.
My personal view is corporations should be
responsible to all stakeholders.
Now, when we say stakeholders, that's bigger
than shareholders.
Stakeholders includes society.
It includes the economy.
More broadly, it includes the environment.
This is not the way corporations operate.
So all sorts of different companies we've
seen Target, Home Depot, Etsy, H and M on
the list of companies supporting Black Lives
Matter, some donating to Black Lives Matter
and affiliated causes.
I don't really think it matters in terms of
figuring out the morality of these companies.
Tons of companies have said, you know, we're
committed to fighting injustice.
Some say they're committed to dealing with
systemic racism.
Others are donating money, whatever.
Now, to the extent that they're handing cash
over, the money can be used to fight these
battles.
And that's good.
And the money is money, no matter who donated
it.
But fundamentally, at the corporate level,
these are business calculations.
I was thinking back to my first appearance
on the Joe Rogan program.
We were having a conversation about Google
and Joe felt that Google is a left wing company
because they have a nondiscrimination policy
for trans workers.
That includes you refer to people by their
preferred gender pronouns.
And so Joe felt that Google was a left wing
company on that basis.
My position was that a nondiscrimination policy
from a human resources standpoint doesn't
really tell us whether the company's right
wing or left wing in terms of its place in
the world.
And in fact, I said to Joe, Google is part
of the anti regulation avoid taxes movement
that's often more associated with the right
than the left in the United States.
But the truth is that all of this stuff has
one focus.
How can Google gain market share and how can
Google make more money?
Having the LGBT nondiscrimination policy?
Probably helps their bottom line more than
it hurts it from a preop PR perspective.
Just like lobbying against taxes helps their
bottom line, lobbying against regulation helps
their bottom line and much the same way.
That's the lens through which I see this corporate
support of Black Lives Matter.
Now, it's important to mention I'm not denying
for a second that many of the individuals
who work at these companies probably do support
Black Lives Matter from a personal standpoint.
I am sure that many of them oppose police
brutality.
I am sure that many of the workers and even
executives at these companies agree with the
protests because most of the country agrees
with the reasons for the protests.
But much like I often say, we shouldn't DFI
individual politicians.
They're just people.
They're right on some things, the wrong on
some other things.
We should not attribute certain agency to
corporations when all we can really say is
they've calculated their options and have
made a business decision.
The business decisions might sometimes coincide
with the political feelings of the executive.
You might have a situation where the executive
support Black Lives Matter and supporting
Black Lives Matter is good for the company's
bottom line.
It's all beautiful.
It's all hunky dory kumbayah.
And it's that's the way that that it all goes
down.
But at no point should we lose sight of the
reality that if it were really bad for a corporation
to support Black Lives Matter based on their
customer base and other factors, they would
be dramatically less likely to say, we support
the protests or Black Lives Matter or are
donating.
So tell me what you think.
Am I being overly cynical here on my oversimplifying
some component of this?
I want to hear from you.
I believe that corporate support of Black
Lives Matter.
Not I'm not talking about the individuals
at the companies.
Corporate support of Black Lives Matter is
merely a calculated business decision.
I want to hear from you.
We will have more about this on our insta.
Rampage, which is David Pakman, show all one
word on Instagram.
Follow us there.
We'll take a quick break.
Much more about the John Bolton Donald Trump
scandal coming up after this short break